parfait
on se tue à moi comme je pense à toi
on se tue à ça aussi souvent que moi
penses-tu que c'est la bonne cette fois
on se tue pouvoir me faire oublier la
conne d'avant toi
suis-je bien fait pour toi
dans le matin est-ce que ma tête te
reviendra
j'ai bien foutu que le sentir tes
devoirs
quand ils partent un éclaireur me
chercher sous les draps
est-ce que ça va sourire pour nous si
l'on croise les doigts
est-ce que l'on peut se perdre tout dans
le cou comme ça
aurais-je assez de talents
pour que tu m'aimes tout le temps
proche
il y a une question qui ne me lâche pas
où vont les canards quand il fait trop
froid
penses-tu rester toujours tout près de
moi
saurais jamais t'aimer que celui avant
pourrais-tu mourir dans le creux de mes
bras
est-ce que la jalousie nous dévorera
tu sais question qui me tiennent
toutes ces questions qui me saigne
proche
il y a une question qui ne me quitte
plus
sur quoi tire les chasseurs quand ils
ont trop peu
pourrais-tu me descendre quand la rage
monte du fond de toi
pourrais-je renifle le fond de tes
culottes et quand tu n'es pas là
quand tu auras-tu toujours ma bouche
avec autant de fois
drogue ma bouche toi tu l'as toi tu
approche
il y a cette question qui hante mes
nuits
combien de jours de deuil à la mort de
Johnny
voilà